hello everyone and welcome back to the
second game of the rapid tie breaks of
the 2022 uh fide grand prix currently
being played in berlin it's levon our
numbers hikaru nakamura nakamura have
won his game with the white pieces it
was a very very tough struggle but in
the end he was a little bit faster and
that means a lot when it's a complicated
end game uh he was able to uh to prevail
there and now levon has the white pieces
and he needs to win this in order to
force
to push even further into the tie breaks
or if your car gets a draw here with the
black pieces then hikaru wins the entire
thing rather he wins the first leg of
the video grand prix and he is one step
closer to the candidates tournament so
let's see what's uh
what happened in game two uh levon with
the white pieces opens with e4 uh we
have e5 by hikaru knight to f3 knight to
c6 and bishop to c4 so again we have a
nice uh uh joko piano the italian game
is on the board uh and now uh castles by
white uh so not uh not doing anything
crazy here uh knight to f6 and now rook
to e1 defending d for pawn we have d6
and now c3 so this is all very very
standard stuff we have a6 making room
for the bishop on a7 uh d4 striking in
the center and the bishop back to a7 we
have h3 and now uh
well there are a couple of moves that
were uh played in this position for
example queen to e7 is a normal but here
we have castles and it is now already as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game uh so levon continues
developing we have bishop to e3 and now
uh we have h6 uh if you're thinking
about why not capture the e4 pawn well
it's one of the very well-known tricks
and uh in the joko piano for example if
knight captures an e4 d5 is deadly uh so
what can you play here the knight here
is attacked if you move the knight then
we capture the bishop rook captures we
capture the knight on e4 if you play
something like bishop captures an e3 we
can play rook captures and e3 and now
again the this knight and this knight
are hanging
and if we try knight to a5 so we attack
the the bishop here we just play bishop
to f1 and now what do you do here if you
play f5 defender to defend this knight
or if you move it we play b4 and the
this knight is now trapped no no square
left for this knight or even after rook
captures on e3 uh well there's really no
good move you can make here best is just
play knight captures and have two king
captures and then take it from there in
97 maybe you can now try and make
something here with black but white
should always be better so after bishop
to e3 he car just plays h6 he wants none
of this craziness he only needs a draw
to win uh defeated grand prix we have
bishop back to b3 and now rook to e8
levon very nicely it shows a line where
nothing gets traded off you can see that
all the pawns are still on the board all
the pieces are still on the border he
wants to slow play this as much as
possible and look for some chances
anywhere where hikaru might give him
some so knight b to d2 we have bishop to
d7 continuing development and now queen
b1 defending d for pawn so now the
knight can move maybe you can shift it
over to g3 put it on f5 create some
chances there so queen to e7 and now a3
uh we have queen to f8 hikaru also
nicely just remaneuvering and the queen
back to d3 we have b5 by hikaru and now
levon plays to rook 8 to c1 uh we have
knight to e5 again another standard
maneuver uh we want to
attack the bishop we want to play c5
attack the center and then uh well
either we're gonna force white to open
up the center or to close it permanently
with d5 so bishop back to a2 and levon
is now ready to play bishop to b1 and
then the queen bishop battery will be
well not fully operational but if the e4
pawn moves then it could be could be
important so c5 hikaru strikes against
the center and now b3
uh we have knight back to c6 putting
even more pressure on the d4 pawn uh and
here he uh lavone just closes it with d5
so as you can see still nothing has been
traded we are already on move 18. knight
to the e7 now comes c4 uh
improving the the structure here asking
black do you maybe want to capture on c4
but keycard just goes knight to g6 and
now uh you could consider keeping the
tension with bishop to b1 and just
continue to slow play this but here
levon plays b4 and now there certainly
will be some captures on the board now
the position will open up so here we
have c captures on b4 we have eight
captures and b for b captures and c4
bishop captures on c for bishop captures
an e3 rook captures an e3 and now rook e
to b8 saying okay if you capture on a6
i'm going to capture on b4 and then with
everything traded off in the queen side
uh i mean it's a pretty close structure
in the in the
center nothing much happening on the
king side i'm very happy with the draw a
draw is basically a win for me says
hikaru so here we have uh queen to a3
just defending the b for pawn level 1
cannot really afford to trade this we
have queen to d8 and now bishop back to
f1 but now hikaru just
offers further trades we have bishop to
b5 so here we have queen the a5 levon
offers a queen trait here and hikaru
happily accepts uh but first he trades
even more material bishop captures an f1
queen captures 78 rook captures and now
king captures an f1 now coming rook d to
b8 again putting pressure on the b for
pawn so olive on defense that we have
rook to b3 and now he car plays rook to
b5 he wants to
increase the pressure on the b file even
though a5 is uh pretty much uh an
instant draw but you have to be very
careful now the thing is of course uh if
uh b5 uh you white advances the pawn
okay white has a passport but then we
also have a fast pawn with a4 so that's
one way to do it and another way is that
if you capture here we can capture here
and now yes the knight defends this pawn
but you can grab the e4 pawn now now do
you want to trade this for the past a
pawn yes of course it's easy after the
game to claim that this is a draw but
you know just because it's an equalish
or an equal position does not mean that
it's an immediate draw so uh of course
uh hikaru plays rook to b5 better to
play maybe a a slower move but uh you
know nothing uh no drastic measures have
been taken so here rook b5 knights to e1
and not knight to e8 both players are
now putting their pieces on on optimal
squares knight to d3 and now f5 by hikar
we have f3 f captures on e4 f captures
an e4 and now knight to f4 hikaru offers
further trades so knight captures on f4
he captures and now king to e2 uh levon
starts bringing his king into the game
now rook ate the b8 we want to capture
the pawn on b4
uh so rook c to b1 defending the pawn
and now knight to f6 uh paralyzing the
knight the pawn would hang if the knight
moves so we're going to play king of
three defend our pawn and now g5 so
hikaru is very very happy here there is
not all that much levon can do to create
some chances so knight the c4 now the
knight can move as the at this point is
very well protected the pawn is hanging
here and hikaru again maybe maybe you
can go for something like a5 saying that
okay now we're gonna capture here or you
capture on a5 and then we play rook they
go after this spawn uh but um of course
it's a rapid game you don't want to
spend too much time so hikaru just goes
98 it defends the pawn and now h4 levon
has to create some some chances here we
have rook to c8 attacking the knight
knights to a5 now we have knight to f6
and here we have h captures and g5 h
captures and knight to c6 so this knight
uh certainly yeah made some progress it
was quite a journey now threatening
knights to e7 check to pick up the rook
here so of course rook to e8 uh with a
double attack on the pawn here and now
knight to d4 uh here levon attacks the
rook here uh g4 with check a very nice
trick now inviting the king to capture
on f4 if you don't do this then that's
pretty much a game so king captures on
f4 and now rook captures on e4 with
check now the knight is gonna fall but
okay you don't lose a piece king f5 you
attack the black knight on f6 rook
capture sunday for king captures on f6
and now rook d captures on d5 and now we
have this position where it's hikaru
who's up a pawn but it's something levon
had to allow if he wants to get any
winning chances because for lavon a draw
is basically a loss so he has to play
the game on for as long as possible and
maybe maybe he can win somehow so here
the problem is if a5 happens then uh he
will no longer have any uh motives to
try and create chances to win the game
so he has to move the rooks we have rook
to f1 he doesn't want to trade rooks now
even if a5 we're just going to move the
rook uh so here uh he carl plays a rook
to h5 and hikaru sets a deadly trap but
uh it's very hard to see it and here uh
the thing is you have to play something
like king the g6 you play king the g6
and now we probably have a perpetual
here rook here checking here rook here
king here rook here and it's going to be
a draw by perpetual most likely however
levon cannot allow this he played rook
to f4 and now he is threatening to pick
up this pawn with check but also uh he
just ran into a deadly deadly trap so
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for hikaru and the entire
fida grand prix
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this well
brilliant king hunt and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course rook to h6 with check and now you
see this rook covers the fifth rank this
row covers the sixth rank the king
covers these squares so the only square
left for the white king is the e7 square
this is what levon played now comes rook
b7 check and now look at this this is
the sixth rank this is the seventh rank
only squares available to the white king
are these two squares and it doesn't
matter both of them lose the game uh
levon played king to d8 and now hikaru
played the only winning move and that is
the rook the h8 um probably most likely
the one that levon missed when he played
rook to f4 and now when levon saw this
it was in this position on move 50 that
he resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh it looks like uh
maybe you can defend this wood white but
whatever you try it's not going to work
the black king is simply threatening
king to h7 and then it's going to be
checkmate or rather first you're going
to have to give up the rook and then
it's going to be checkmate so there are
two ways you can try to defend this one
is to attack this rook but then we just
play rook g7 and now there's nothing you
can do king h7 will be checkmate
and on the other hand after rook dha you
could try something like rook to e3 to
meet rook h7 with something like rook
here uh but the white is always a tempo
short for example king h7 check you're
gonna block check but now the other rook
delivers check and now we're gonna pick
up the rook here whatever the white king
plays where you can just pick up the
rook with check and that's it now we're
up rook very very soon we're going to
win the game
so yeah after rook to h8 levon resigned
and hikaru takes wins in both of the
games of the
rapid tie breaks over the feed a grand
prix 2022 so it was a really really
tough match uh in classical as you've
seen uh neither player could do anything
but it seems that the the the faster the
timeform it gets the stronger hikaru
gets and here hikaru was just better out
playing lavon in both games in the end
game okay it's always like that if one
player wins the first game then in the
second one the other has to take more
and more chances and then this is the
most likely result uh however
you know but sorry regardless it was a a
fine showing by by both lemon and hikaru
uh so a big congratulations to hikaru
we'll see what happens in the next two
legs of defeated grand prix hikaru is
now closer and closer to the candidates
tournament will we see hikaru in the
candidates tournament or will hikarl
only win a spot in the candidates and
then give it away to ding liran as he uh
mentioned we'll see what happens but uh
chess as always is very interesting uh
so yeah that's the game and this very
short coverage of the fiji grand prix
2022 hope you guys enjoyed that uh i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to paul worthington and i would like to
thank francis air the emoji pillow on my
couch adult and lucifer 45
non-commercial ep for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day